we're back on the old ancient archer
game engine i've got some exciting
things to show you
like this bounty board yeah here it is
you can just find it right here under
projects
and there's a bunch of things that
coders or game engine programmers can
can do and add to this engine and i'll
send send you money
that's how it goes so take a look at the
bounty board if you're a c
plus plus coder and if you can do any of
these things then
hooray you just got to get to them
before other people
or me which shouldn't be too hard some
of them are actually pretty easy i just
don't know what the heck i'm doing
sometimes or i'm busy
so uh yeah have some fun and uh
make a pull request all right other big
news in the engine
we are actually releasing builds can you
believe it
we've got version one which
has some notes about all the stuff that
generally works
and i've already released the next
version two
fixes a few things it's not too bad we
started adding some uh
interfaces the big things and i
refactored a bunch of stuff
so let's take a look at it hello visual
studio
all right welcome so
here is the example project that we're
running
this is just an application that is
attached to the library this is uh
an implementation so to speak or an
example of making a game or whatever
doing stuff the library the actual
library is right here
in the includes you will see ancient
archer
folder and here are the public headers
the only one you really need to include
is this one here so yeah we're gonna
look at example project
and take a quick peek at how it goes
let's go ahead and run that sucker
it's going right down through this main
it's gonna spit out this stuff in the
console
a knit run through all these functions
which just help set up things
uh oh we've got some build errors oh
i've gotta switch to a different branch
hold on a second all right switch to the
branch i'm supposed to be on
reload rebuild oh i've still got a bunch
of
extra stuff in here that shouldn't be in
here
all right there we go much better
so example project is building
it's doing great there we go and it
launches
so i'm going to press tab and i have
that program to open up this inventory
like thing which is just an example of
the gui
so it tells you all the hotkeys you can
press in this mode
tab puts you into this inventory thing
and you can see i messed with the alpha
on hover so the on hover is
calculating okay this guy is still just
uh
spinning because hey sample
all right we got some audio working of
course
so yeah take a look at the repo please
do give it a start
check out the projects check out the
bounty board
check out the code and let's get this
project
off the ground i'm really excited to
make an actual game with it
and to get there i definitely need some
help it's a lot of work
yeah i guess i should also mention this
is purely
coming out of my own pocket whatever i'm
paying so
i'm literally putting my own money into
this at this point not sponsored by any
big corporation or
anything but there is something you
could do to help me out
as a i don't know my own sponsor i guess
there's never been
a better time to get involved in crypto
it's a wild wild world you can join
coinbase and get some free bitcoin
as well and i'll get some free bitcoin
you do have to deposit at least a
hundred bucks
okay so if you join with my link you
will get ten dollars in bitcoin which
could be who knows how much when bitcoin
goes to a million because you know it
will someday you just know it will
you both get free bitcoin when a friend
buys or sells a hundred dollars worth of
crypto so yeah all you got to do is just
like
sign up buy some bitcoin it's kind of
low right now it looks like it's gonna
spike back
up i know don't take my word for it do
your own research
make your own decisions but obviously
you want to have some way to get
involved in crypto you might as well get
started on coinbase and uh use my link
and we'll both profit so like double
sponsored
not only am i sponsored you're sponsored
all right click that link
let's uh let's make some let's make some
cool game engine stuff
so if these don't get solved i will up
the bounty at some point if like they're
just sitting here for a month and
nobody's figured them out or out of them
so eventually they'll have such a high
bounty
that nobody will be able to turn it down
and they'll have to
they'll have to help out i just want
this engine to be off the ground it's
something
that i love i'm gonna talk about a
little more okay for warning
this might be a bit scattered because
it's a lot to cover
and i'm gonna try to do it quickly so
feel free to ask questions or
join the discord link down below to join
the discord
and we can talk about it even more there
okay the main project to work on
is this aaa engine solution up here
below is just some projects that already
have it pre-linked i've talked about
these kind of projects in the previous
couple videos too i believe
they're basically just implementations
of the engine so if you're adding a
feature
or you're fixing something it's in
general going to be in source so
everything here in source
and end user or someone making a project
off this engine
won't have direct access to source they
have to go
through the publicly available functions
in this
ancient archer header so you can build
whatever features you want
but ultimately they're all linked
together and managed
by these functions here so
every function that is publicly
available
will implement your functions and and do
all that stuff
so ultimately when you init the engine
it fires everything up the windowing and
all that
the graphics and when you hit run it
starts the core loops the core loops are
private
but they have all this stuff that you
mess with auto managed
to some extent like if you add
a prop or model and it has a lit shader
it's going to automatically use the
lights you have
if you have it with just a diff shader
it's going to ignore the lights
so some of that stuff is automatic all
the data
is hidden you will find it in the cpp
class
and it's all declared near the top
everything is always in the name space
of aa
so these are things that are used in the
loop just know that all the loop code is
also in here
as well as the implementations of these
functions
and if there's any held variables like
we have the list of objects and the list
of lights and all that stuff
or vectors of them rather those are all
held
privately and managed through these
functions of add and remove
and everything works off of ids if it
has an id
the class has a base type with a unique
id
so you can it's basically
a rudimentary system of keeping track of
unique things
and being able to access them by their
unique
i encourage you to dig through some more
that's kind of an overview of it
thank you all so much for watching a
huge shout out
to my patrons i really appreciate you
guys
and uh yeah don't forget to check out
coinbase get involved in crypto join the
discord
just imagine all the things i should say
here and that i said them
well all right i'll see you guys in the
next video
thanks again for watching matt from
codetech tutorials over and out
look forward to chatting with you guys
[Music]
soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
you